we're asked to convert 10 to the second
power or 10 squared equals 100 into a
logarithmic equation now this is saying
if I take the base 10 so I'm going to do
10 in yellow I take the base 10 to the
exponent 2 then I get then I get 100
when you do a logarithm it's really kind
of the inverse of that it's really kind
of the other way of thinking about it a
logarithm says what power what power do
I have to raise the base to what power
do I have to raise the base to to get
100 to get 100 so if I were to write log
base 10 of 100 I wrote the 10 a little
bit bigger than is typically done and we
write this way
log base 10 of 100 this says what power
do I have to raise tan to my base to get
100 and we know from this and actually
you probably knew even if we didn't have
this written down you would have to
raise it to the second power so this is
equal to this is equal to 2 so right
over here we're saying in an exponential
equation the base 10 to the second power
is equal to 100 here in the logarithmic
equation we're saying the power that we
have to raise 10 to to get 100 is equal
to 2 so these are really saying these
are really saying the exact same thing
and just so you get the terminology
right this in both cases the 10 is
referred to as the base this is the base
and in both cases the 2 let me write it
so in both cases the 2 is referred to
and I think you know this already as the
exponent as the exponent and then the
hundred is what you get when you raise
the base to the exponent so these are 2
both 2 ways of writing the exact same
truth about 10 to the second power
equaling a hundred